给大家分享一条干活,这条视频能看懂的人不多,但是一旦看懂了一会发现,哇,原来是原来是这个样子,好后理解下面的句话,就在公月时代,你只有做出的那个产品,你才能买钱,办成品去吃飙钱的,比如说做个起初,还有个车我们开有,这个之前,你说我把这个,我做的一把我给你形容,不行,但是在一遇,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,
就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就会说,就
这个数就值钱
所以各位你平时读书的笔记
就不是灾抄的句子
是你灾抄完以后你的理解
如果你在把它转化成对别人有用的
对别人医于理解的
那么一个有用的知识
你比如说把它写成一段小文字
我的把它开成一头视频
可能也就是养人习惯了可能一种十分钟
八分钟是
就能陪你大概大量的用户
我的这个张号就是这么来的
所以我拍短的评
十分钟之内
就是把我一些想法说一出一出一
好注意啊
你的笔记学习笔记是可以赚钱的
第二
你失败的点是可以赚钱的
我看好多人啊
我不懂做事啊
我要还怕失败
你告诉我怎么成功啊怎么就过去
对吧
其实你会发现失败才有价值
因为你说的可能别人也可能会说
然后你说来的看怎么爬上那个经验对别人有用
所以你完全可以写闭空之单
而如果你掉了空里面走出来这些传都是财富
所以我看很能就还怕失败
失败就是财富啊你好好去体贵这一点吧
然后第三个
从领导义的那个过程
我看今天我们还要聊好就说
我想我做什么事老想去找那个最优劫
女传
从领导义很重要
大部分人
举预刀问题都是什么都是从导义的
我也是个参加了我伤的不会呀
我到底怎么拍的是谁呀
我到底怎么去吃波呀我到底怎么投资啊
大量的人就这种群众基础才多呢对吧
人们是需要这种从领导义的交成的
一旦一个是你做成的
就好的你说你别让我去做的
你给我个工具
不需要你的计刀我也可以能把这个事做成
一把他做成一个产品做成一个魔法的什么PBT魔法呀什么有点魔法呀什么奴着魔法呀
哎呀提示此啊
这些东西都可以做成品
然后你的经验复盘
你像我来这里之前的话呢
我会可以一些企业做资讯
然后的资源飞用很高啊
为什么呢
一用每次做成或者失败的时候我都会去总结
然后取一反散啊
这个问题的背后的原因是什么
那么遇到同一问题在说的话呢我都我都可以有些绝法那很多时候啊你怎么会这么多
其实就是因为你愿意总结愿意复盘
然后去抽象
然后可以把它
用在别的地方
所以看到没
我为什么跟大家说一定要在大听广中下工作因为你做的那个事情啊比如说一个
一个俱乐你可能是费我
但在不同的人员里说澳洲还有这个东西有钱对吧你能想到吗
你的读书笔记需要钱的
你十八产这个这个经历啊那个经验是要钱的
从能到于那个盘个过程是要钱的
你做成完那个事也可以赞钱
对你的总结经验也可以赠钱
所以各位好好体会这以后啊在工业号时代你只有做成那个产品才能赚钱
办成品是不是钱的
但是在移动或者往事的
啊你做完那个产品你的过程包括实体
都之前所以做事的方法是什么
是逼的硬爬不了一个从现在开始
认真做好一件小事
把它做好做完整
最好在大听广中下工作
这样的话呢你会发现你又学到了之水
你有结交的朋友同时
还转到了钱